have received at least one shot
including nearly 90 percent of seniors
and 70 of adults over the age of 27.
by the end of this week we'll have
reached a mark of 160 million fully
vaccinated americans
and that's a goal i set in march that
i'm thrilled we're going to hit
just a few days after july the 4th
so we will have 160 million
fully vaccinated americans up from
roughly 3 million when we took office
five months ago
we see why it matters cover 19 cases
and deaths are down by 90 since january
millions of fully vaccinated americans
are getting back to
they're living their lives as they did
before
businesses are reopening and hiring and
rehiring
and projected economic growth is the
highest
it's been projected growth is the
highest it's been in four decades
and the bottom line is the virus is on
the run and america is coming back
we're coming back together this is one
of the greatest achievements in american
history and you
the american people made it happen but
our fight against this virus is not over
right now as i speak to you millions of
americans are still unvaccinated
and unprotected and because of that
their communities are at risk their
friends are at risk the people that they
care about are at risk
this is an even bigger concern because
of the delta variant
in today's briefing we discussed how the
delta variant is already responsible for
half of
all cases in many parts of this country
it's more easily transmissible
potentially more dangerous
and it should be because of
reconsideration
and look let me put another way
it seems to me it should cause everybody
to think twice
and it should cause reconsideration
especially
young people who may have thought that
they didn't have to be
vaccinated to worry about it didn't have
to do anything about it up to now
but the good news is that our
vaccinations are
highly effective fully vaccinated
americans have a high degree of
protection
including against this delta variant
study after study after study has shown
that since early may
virtually every covet 19 hospitalization
and death in the united states has been
among the unvaccinated
so if you're vaccinated you're protected
but if you're unvaccinated you're not
and you're putting yourself more
importantly maybe from your perspective
your family
and your friends at risk so please get
vaccinated now
it works it's free it's never been
easier and it's never been more
important
do it now for yourself and the people
you care about
for your neighborhood for your country
it sounds corny
but it's a patriotic thing to do in
today's briefing
we discussed how our administration is
going to devote the remainder of the
summer
to a special focus on five ways to make
gains in getting those of you who are
unvaccinated vaccinated
because here's the deal we are
continuing to wind down the mass
vaccination sites that did so much in
the spring
to rapidly vaccinate those eager to get
their first shot
and their second shot for that matter if
they needed a second
now we need to go to community by
community neighborhood by neighborhood
and often door-to-door literally
knocking on doors
to get help to the remaining people
protected from the virus
look equity equality it remains at the
heart of our responsibility of ensuring
the communities
that are the hardest hit by the virus
have the information
and the access to get vaccinated so
as we shift from these centralized mass
vaccination sites we're
doing thousands of people a day we're
going to put even more emphasis on
getting vaccinated in your community
close to home conveniently
and a location you're already familiar
with
first first thing we're going to do this
includes 42
000 local pharmacies where folks with
questions can talk to the pharmacist
they know and already have done what
they dealt with
these locations overwhelmingly allow you
to walk in
without an appointment get the
vaccination
when you're picking up your prescription
or just going in to get
your toothpaste or something else you
need from a drugstore
second my team is going to place renewed
emphasis on getting the vaccines
to more and more family doctors and
health care providers
so more americans will get this shot at
their doctor's office
from the folks that they know and they
trust the most third
thing we're going to do we're going to
step up efforts to get vaccines to your
family doctors and other doctors who
serve
younger people so the adolescents ages
12 to 18 can get vaccinated
and as they go for back to school
checkups
or getting ready for the physicals they
need for fall sports
fourth we're also intensifying our
efforts to meet people
where they are outside of the
neighborhoods pharmacies and doctors
office this includes
continuing to work with employers to
make vaccination shots available at work
on the work site if possible
get error and or give their employees
paid time off to get vaccinated to
nearby
facility and fifth and finally
we're sending out more mobile clinic
more more mobile clinic units out there
to help people with special events
summer festivals sporting events as well
as places of worship wherever we can
find people
gathered in addition to these
initiatives to continue to vaccinate the
unvaccinated
we're stepping up our preparations to
respond to the outbreaks we're going to
see among the unvaccinated
for that we're mobilizing what i'm
calling covet 19
surge response teams these teams are
made up of experts from
fema the federal emergency management
agency
cdc the center for disease control and
prevention
and elsewhere across our government
other groups
and they're going to help states have
particular problems
prevent detect and respond to the spread
of the delta variant among unvaccinated
people
in communities with low vaccination
rates and some states have
very low vaccination rates they're going
to be able to
do we're going to deploy things like
testing to expand detection of the virus
medicines to help treat the infected and
we're going to provide
federal personnel to fill gaps in
staffing and technical experts to help
investigate
outbreaks because they're going to
happen in states with very low
vaccination rates
the bottom line is my administration is
doing everything it can
to lead a whole of government response
at the federal
state and local levels to defeat the
pandemic
we need everyone to do their part
millions of americans have already done
that
we have to keep it up though we have to
keep it up till we're finished
let me close with this we are emerging
from one of the darkest years in our
nation's history
into a summer of hope and joy hopefully
think about where you were where you
were last year
where you are today what you were able
to do last year at this time and do
today
it's a year of hard-fought hard-fought
progress
we can't get complacent now
the best thing you can do to protect
yourself and your family and the people
you care about the most
is get vaccinated
the best things community can do to
protect themselves is to increase
vaccination rates you can do this you
can do this
let's finish the job finish it together
god bless you all and please please
get vaccinated it makes a big difference
as i said it's a patriotic thing to do
may god protect our troops thank you mr
president on the latest ransomware
attack can you tell us if you believe
that rises to the level of u.s
retaliation
i can tell you a couple things i
received an update from my national
security team this morning
it appears to have caused minimal damage
to u.s businesses but we're still
gathering information
to the full extent of the attack and i'm
going to have more to say about this
in the next several days we're getting
more detail and information
that's what i can tell you now and i
feel good about
our ability to uh
mr putin testing you sir
okay